hey folks it's Friday again and that
means it's time for another movie
retrospective doing something a little
different today we're doing a double
feature yep same director yeah we don't
usually we don't usually do this type of
thing but it just kind of happened that
I had actually been wanting to do the
movie dead and buried
from 1981 for a really long time and I
was very happy to see last week that
shutter had added it to their lineup and
then while I was looking at it I was
like oh they also added Gary Sherman's
earlier movie from 1970 to 1973 which is
called death line probably better known
in the United States as raw meat yeah so
I decided why don't we just do two of
them cuz they're both sort of zombie
movies yeah zombie cannibal type stuff
going on even though not really what
you'd expect they did something kind of
different with them and shudders been
rocking I mean they look those guys are
awesome so much we've been giving them
free plugs and it's for y'all you got
you guys might have some people can get
deals for this like 399 a month yeah
all right five bucks but yeah you paid
five I saw an offer for like 399 online
yeah okay and they have some exclusives
we saw an exclusive movie from shudder
yesterday I think was badass is called
Mandy Mandy yes yeah I'll start casting
it - it was weird man yeah it was good I
liked same guy that did be on the black
rainbow right because when I whole time
I was watching it and I'm sitting there
going god this is a lot like beyond the
black rainbow it's like really weird and
trippy like that imagine you get
abducted by this evil cult alright and
this like this evil sex cult and they
give you some LSD that just seems to be
irreversible it's super powerful and
you're trying to get escape this cult
and deal with it other influences of
like this evil LSD and you're seeing
just what you're just seeing just what
Nicholas Cage is seeing you're not crazy
Nicholas Cage's imagine Nicholas Cage
also bad acid he's yeah in the custody
of a weird sex cult you're gonna love
the movies awesome I know it's what like
I said it's been getting a lot of buzz
and shudder we're very excited that they
got an exclusive yeah cuz I've been
seeing ads for like three months and
we're not you know we don't shutter
doesn't pay us alright shut her needs to
start paying us
the plugs that we give no I'm just
saying I really like that good service I
like that service and it's everything
that Netflix isn't Netflix gives you
good mainstream stuff they have some
little things this is like a lot of
really cool classic stuff and new stuff
all [ __ ] yeah I like the things that
they kind of like do half-and-half
between old ones and new ones because
that seems like a really good
combination yeah and like I said they
just added dead and buried they had a
death line they added a whole bunch of
Stephen King ones like from the 80s they
added maniac yeah so they also added
Christmas evil which is probably what I
was gonna do black Christmas because
they have that too but I was like oh
well Christmas evil is a little less
well known I think so
so for somewhere between four five six
bucks a month you can get this awesome
service that's really oriented towards
the kind of people that also subscribe
to 13 o'clock really yeah and they have
cereal sound movie rental yeah oh yeah
I'm serious and stuff too but I haven't
even like looked into that yeah cuz I'm
so busy watching like trying to you know
I'm so busy getting through all the
movies so you could play it on your xbox
your ps1 or what's known the new Sony
PlayStation's you know they have asked
for it so we watch it through that we
watch it 2x and I watched on my
definitely sometimes - in my office
regular computer but anyway so yeah like
I said I've been wanting to do dead and
buried for such a long time because I
don't you know what's weird I don't
think I saw this back in the day um I'm
I guess we'll talk about dead and buried
first because even though death mine is
older we just saw dead and buried like
last night and then death line we saw a
couple nights ago
so I remember this one better but I had
actually it was on cable a lot like in
the mid 80s so I feel like I always kind
of saw that it was on but somehow I
always ended up missing it and then just
recently you know I like to go through
um you know of people's lists of like
most underrated horror movies from the
70s didn't see if there's like anything
I missed out on and this one comes up on
there a lot so I finally was like you
know finally shut her out of it and I
was like alright cool we're gonna watch
it now like I said this is kind of like
a zombie movie but not like any kind of
zombie movie it's almost like a
Lovecraft a zombie movie
yeah outta like re animator happening in
a situation that's kinda like in Sethe
and the overall effect in some ways it's
kind of like the movie this the fog it
gives me that's the same vibe as if you
can imagine like something sort of like
the fog something like a weird like Ray
Bradbury type story or like a twilight
zone type story also combined with like
an HP Lovecraft and slightly HP
Lovecraft type of vibe because it's like
a seaside town called Potter's Bluff and
it's supposed to be in Rhode Island
although I think they actually filmed it
in Mendocino County California but like
they film everything in California but
it's supposed to be Rhode Island it's
like a fishing village and this this
movie has one of the best like opening
sequences in this in you know in the
sense that I want to find out what the
[ __ ] is going on in this movie it's like
is the first thing this guy he's a
photographer he shows up in this town
and he's like walking along the beach
he's like oh look at the beautiful
scenery and he starts taking pictures
and then all of a sudden this little
blonde hottie shows up and starts
flirting like hardcore and like a normal
person would be like red flag red flag
you know what I mean because this woman
is like clearly clearly either some kind
of you know I mean this doesn't happen
as a man I know I see this [ __ ] going
down I go that don't happen that's not
bad at getting ready to happen and
that's pretty much this Falls right and
he yeah and I'm just like oh my god if I
want to do some murder the whole town's
murdering people it's weird
yeah and they seem normal yeah and you
don't know what the hell's going on the
cop starts investigating and he just
finds out are we really prize movies
probably good enough and old enough and
unknown enough maybe to try to protect
some of the spoilers yeah yeah because I
guess I am you or generation and I
barely remembered this movie from my
childhood yeah I put it on HBO I pretty
sure I came across that I mean some of
those scenes are super familiar and that
vibe is super familiar every
I've saw we've watched it twice for this
review yeah and I was like I know I've
seen this movie I remember seeing that I
remember seeing this I remember and I
don't think I truly understood what it
was I was seeing back then you kind of
just may attend to the dialogue just
remember that it was really weird and I
remember the end there was a video game
on Xbox one a long time ago it was the
main character was this guy named torque
and he was a prisoner and he was insane
and he was hallucinating and some of the
stuff from that video game about film
projectors and guys talking to you I
think they got it from this movie it
never is a bullsh or never at the very
end the guy starts turning on all the
film projectors yeah no one what one of
the characters had done over over over
her history yeah just
it was weird it's really weird movie and
it has a very Lovecraftian vibe it's
almost kind of it's like a weird creepy
sort of supernatural police procedural
yeah it's more like a mystery than a
straight-up horror movie even though
it's got a lot of gore in it almost kind
of like Wicker Man where a cop is
investigating the entire yeah it has a
wicker man kind of vibe to a little bit
um it's sort of like like I said you
know this this guy comes there you know
this chick starts like flirting with him
and stuff and he's like who would you
know he doesn't think Oh too good to be
true he's like yeah I'm gonna jump on
that and then all of a sudden you know
he gets set on fire and then then you
find out like as I said the cop who is
actually I didn't realize this the first
time I watched it cuz I wasn't paying
attention I guess cuz I'm just drinking
but like the second time I watched it
cuz I'm sitting there going wall why
didn't the cop know all this stuff was
going on before but it's because he's
new he's new in town
like he had gone away like he was from
that town when he was born and then he
went to like the big city and like went
to cop school and all that other kind of
stuff where he like he got a criminology
degree or whatever and he came back to
his hometown to take over the sheriff
job so he hadn't been there for many
many years so this is basically like a
thing where it's got this really great
like creepy vibe like this whole
paranoia thing because you don't know
like who in town is in on this [ __ ] yeah
and like I said I don't really want to
spoil like what the secret actually is
because it's actually pretty interesting
I don't think I've seen another movie
with this type of vibe but yeah this
movie is not famous you know I mean it's
like really yeah not good movie I know
I've seen this I know I've seen this
before
and I forgot all about it yeah I'm glad
that that shutter brought it back up
because I was like oh yeah yeah like I
said I just kept hearing that's creepy
one because the poster is fantastic I
love the poster for this movie it's so
striking to like I said you know I don't
think I saw it I remember it being on
cable back in the day but I don't think
I saw it back then but it's it's one
that comes up on a lot of people's
radars like a very very underrated like
80s horror maybe one that doesn't get
much attention but that is actually
really good like I said I think I know
this might be a controversial statement
but I actually think I like this a bit
better than the fog yeah its gory ER for
sure Stan winds delivers a lot Stan
Winston actually did the special effects
for this which actually other than one
scene with like a fake head that looks a
little fakie but like all of the other
special effects in this look really
really good yeah I love that the dude
that played Grandpa Joe in Willy Wonka
and the Chocolate Factory back of that
that nice nice old man is like a really
good character you know against the tape
you've already kind of spilled the beans
it's a zombie movie but it's not a
zombie it's not like I said it's not
like a traditional zombie yeah dead
people are doing stuff and in there
they're indistinguishable from living
people it's a trip that's what I mean
it's like one you don't know why like
this cop is investigating all these
murders that are happening he doesn't
know who's doing them there were like
really horrible murders like I said dude
get set on fire like you'd appreciate
girls heads yeah a girl gets her head
crushed in with a rock like a dude gets
all sliced up and and you know dude gets
acid put up his nose yeah make him
inhale her acid yeah and stuff like that
so he's investing he can't figure out
who's doing it and then you have the
whole thing because you know who's doing
it because you see but the cop doesn't
know so it's like this really horrible
and you're like why are these people
doing this and
then there's like mysterious stuff where
he's like walk around he's like hey that
looks like the dude that died it's like
why is he fine and all this other stuff
so it's like you don't really know
what's going on and it's like super
creepy and like I said there's this
great feeling of like this creepy
paranoia of like what all these people
do like what is their endgame who's in
on it who knows about it yet how is this
happening well how can how could the
dead rise like this you know why are
they yeah that kind of stuff and also oh
I should note that the sheriff's wife is
played by melody Anderson who's probably
most famous for playing good old Dale
Arden but in from Flash Gordon yeah
there's there's cuties in this movie
yeah this was like I think this was a
year after Flash Gordon yeah who wrote
this the same guy who wrote alien 1 yeah
oh yeah I forgot to mention that this
actually played well here's what it was
the the screenplay for this was written
by a Ronald Shusett and Dan O'Bannon who
were the two guys very famously who
wrote the screenplay for alien now later
on I've heard that Dan O'Bannon came out
and said well I didn't really write the
script like Ronald Shusett wrote it and
I gave him notes on it and he said he
was gonna incorporate the notes but then
I saw the movie and he didn't
incorporate the notes so I don't know
how true that is like I've just heard
that Dan O'Bannon said that you know I
didn't really have that much
contribution into the script so it was
mostly ronald choose it but like i said
same you know relative team that went
into alien um and actually this movie
here's something that i read and i
didn't notice this the first time that i
watched it so I looked for it the second
time the way that it's shot like I said
it's very much like the fog it's
something like cool colors like
everything's kind of like gray and
drained and stuff um there's no red in
it except for blood and there's a little
bit at the beginning and like a little
bit at the end that's the only time that
the filmmaker like the cinematographer
the director or whatever like put red in
it so this is like a very well thought
out the visuals of it are well thought
out the story of it it's got some really
creepy cemetery scenes yeah and it's
like the score is good it's like every
it's just like a really good like
low-key creepy movie with with some
decent gore effects like it's fairly
gory um you know if there's gory or ones
from that time but this one is actually
a fairly gory and the special
are actually very good because like I
said Stan Winston did them other than
one that was a little bit a little bit
fakie looking but other than that like
they're all really good and always good
for the time yeah yeah it's in I feel
like it's one that kind of gets
forgotten about yeah this one this one
needs to be brought back yeah but this
one showed this one yeah like I said I
had actually had this on the list for a
really long time because like I said I
kept seeing an underrated list and then
when it came up I was like woohoo and
then I saw that they had done you know
the director's name I don't remember I
don't know if we mentioned it but it's
Gary a Sherman this was actually his
second movie now like I said it came out
in 1981 now his first movie famously was
actually made in the UK even though Gary
Sherman is American and it came out in
the UK in 1972 and it came out in the
u.s. in 1973 now in the UK is called
death line but in the u.s. it's called
raw meat for some I mean I guess I know
why but here's the thing now in the 70s
and 80s there are famously a lot of
really really misleading poster art but
this has got to be I mean this is up
there with some misleading poster art
you can tell not only did the u.s.
distributor rename this movie raw meat
but they also made the poster it's like
this illustration it's the same one I
used for the title card it's like this
kind of painting of all these like
half-naked looking people that it look
all wild and [ __ ] like they're supposed
to be cannibals it's supposed to look
like cannibal ferox or Cannibal
Holocaust they try to obviously they
wanted the poster to look like that so
you could be forgiven for watching this
movie and being like what the [ __ ] this
is a because while there is technically
cannibalism in this yeah it's not like a
cannibal like you know what I mean it's
not like you're thinking of it right
it's not like an Italian cannibal
exploitation movie it's not really like
that it's actually mostly just like dead
and buried it is it's almost moutains is
mostly a police procedural yeah frankly
yeah kind of stars guy Donald Pleasance
Donald Pleasence doesn't play as a total
dick he's funny he is like super [ __ ]
wonderful yeah he's like so because I
had fun doing this yeah it's like you
yeah he plays like the the little main
police inspector now the interesting
about the thing about this is like the
reason it's called death line in the UK
is just because the story is based
around an urban legend that there were
all these miners or like people working
on a tube station or working on a line
you know underground like back in the
1800s and it fell in on them and the
company that was building you know the
tunnel like didn't even bother to go in
and get them so there's like an urban
legend that these people were still
alive down there and they were so kind
of kinda like chudd you know
cannibalistic guess what they were so
alive down there yeah so that's the
thing so that's where that whole think
I'm sorry but like I said that at the
beginning like the cops don't know that
so one of the first people that they
notice that disappears is like this guy
he like collapses and the tube station
and these two students find him and then
they come back you know then they go get
a cop and then the cop comes back and
then the guy is gone and then they find
out that the guy was like was like an
OBE so you know he was like an upper
class twit or whatever so the
interesting thing about this movie too
is that it almost has it's a very
British movie even though it's an
American director but always Christopher
Lee is in it also he doesn't have a huge
part but he's like an mi5 guy and he's
very twee and snotty and stuff which is
it's really kind of funny so it's kind
of like it's almost kind of like a thing
again about the surface world right and
then the cannibals like underneath the
you know the subway tunnels and it's
almost kind of like a class thing too
because Donald Pleasence is characters
the cop is kind of like a very
working-class like the way he talks and
[ __ ] like that he's very working-class
and then he's kind of like putted odds
against this like you know tough
you know like Christopher Lee who's kind
of like telling him don't investigate
this and blah blah because I think he
kind of knows something about it yeah so
that's kind of an interesting thing to
where it has like this weird like
metaphorical thing going on and it's
almost kind of like it has elements of
black comedy and I forgot to mention
that dead and buried when it was first
written then shot it was actually
written and shot as a black comedy but
then when they when it was shown to the
distributors or the producers they said
I don't like that recut it so it's more
like a horror movie
and so it's funny because there are
little funny things in it but you would
never know that that was shot as a
comedies just goes to show the magic of
editing I suppose yeah and the
soundtrack that that's a huge thing too
especially in horror movies I think
that's kind of an underrated
contribution all this stuff that goes on
yes what you have kind of in in this one
and raw meat or what's that slide line
imagine cut is it kind of like Castle
freak yeah I scream Castle freak and the
descent in a way where you know some
church ugh subterranean cannibal yeah
yeah snatching people and eating them
and then then you find out more about
that situation and it was pretty good I
think out of the two I'm gonna have to
give it to dead buried better but
they're both worth watching yeah I like
dead and buried better it's more it's
more accomplished it's more it's
creepier is warrior yeah the execution
is just better I think yeah the idea is
a lot better because it's it's
definitely to me dead and buried dead
buried is a Lovecraft spin-off yeah
that's like something that's like
something they would try to make a
Lovecraft movie it did give me a very
shadow over Innsmouth yeah by way of Ray
Bradbury vibe took a lot of those
concepts that you would see in a
Lovecraft story and put her together
yeah it's a more original story for sure
yeah a lot more original but there's
like I said now perhaps I don't know I
mean yeah there was a lot of cannibal
movies and stuff that came out in the
70s you know particularly from Italy so
cannibalism was not hugely original this
one is kind of like like I said it's it
has some gory parts but it's not super
gory it's mostly focused on the police
procedural and kind of the character
meshing and an interesting thing an
interesting choice that they made with
this one too is that the cannibal who is
not actually given a name he's just
called the man but he's actually a lot
more sympathetic than any people any of
the like other people in the movie which
I thought was kind of an interesting
choice so it's
kind of like it's interesting because we
were watching maniac last night - and
you almost kind of feel sorry for that
guy
- but sort of like he's a little bit
sympathetic he's like a creep and
everything and a murderer obviously and
that's horrible but he has a little bit
of you know you feel a little bit of
sympathy for him because he was so
messed up I like Ron Jeremy gone wrong
very very very wrong but it but in this
in raw meat or death line you feel yes
the cannibal he's like yeah they're
eating people and stuff like that but
you feel bad it's like he didn't have
any control over his situation so he's a
lot more sympathetic and like I said all
the people up on the surface world are
just these snarky [ __ ] that are just
like constantly sniping at each other
and particularly the cops and stuff and
like the Donald Pleasence I love when
the [ __ ] students like first come to
report the stuff and he's just like what
are you probably just stole the [ __ ]
from him and he was just he's just like
busting his balls like the whole time
he's like look man I'm just trying to
like report it dude that was collapsed
in the [ __ ] subway station you know
excuse me for reporting something next
time I'll just [ __ ] leave it there
yeah but yeah so like I said this was um
it was actually a pretty well reviewed
movie when it came out in the 70s even
Roger Ebert thought it was really good
like I even read a review from the time
where the person liked it better than
Night of the Living Dead which that
stuff yeah that's kind of I don't know
how the Living Dead as a classic yeah
and it's it's different it's a different
type of thing it's really not even in
the same I don't know I'd say it's not
the same genre but it's like if they're
two different to compare the same like
yeah it's really not like I said it's
not a zombie movie it's a cannibal movie
but it's not like you know oh let's go
to this island with like a whole you
know the Living Dead I used everything
it did it changed movies yeah yeah I
made every zombie movie since then just
came from that game from that
except for dead and buried right because
that even though Romero didn't say they
were zombies he just said that they were
ghouls yeah they never used the word
zombie kind of well he didn't know yeah
he didn't know that
he is not really a dead person a zombie
is a person underneath the spell who
everybody thinks is dead name up and
he's your slave yeah so technically
Dombey is not really a dead technically
we're using zombie and correct he's not
a dead word they came back yeah a dead
creature an undead creature that feeds
off a corpses or living people that
would be a goal yeah so actually that
when Romero was right that yet they're
ghouls they're not zombies yeah I think
just later on I yeah now I'm kind of
curious as to why that happened like why
the zombie ghoul like I saw a
documentary on it was because nobody
knew at the time that they were
promoting these movies nobody knew what
a ghoul what it was but they had they
already were familiar with the idea of a
zombie yeah things could come out of a
grave yeah even though like I said
technically just like he's on serpent in
the rainbow yeah that's a zombie movie
that's a zombie movie because that he
wasn't dead they just gave him a drug
thing you know that brought him back so
he but he didn't die and then come back
he was just like I think Bella goes he's
white zombie was that was yeah that was
and I watch with the zombie that was
also a zombie because before Romero
came along in 1968 night of the Living
Dead you know I think pretty much every
there weren't a lot of zombie movies but
all of them were like that were voodoo
based yeah because that's where the myth
came from yeah so you know yeah
technically serpent in the rainbow
that's that's a zombie movie yeah all
the other ones are google movies if this
one is a cross between I would say it's
it's a zombie movie
and a ghoul movie yeah what's dead it
dead and buried yeah dead a bear yeah
they are they are dead yeah and but they
are they are under the control of I
guess possibly voodoo yeah yeah it's
yeah but but they are dead they are dead
though yeah so it's kind of like a
combination between a Jew and like I
said I think the best part of dead and
buried was what's that kid what's that
guy's name jack albertson right jack
albertson I think well I'm gonna look it
up on Wikipedia yeah jack albertson the
guy that played Grandpa Joe and Willy
Wonka like I said among many other
things but he always plays like a nice
grandfatherly figure he's like really
good and that's one of the great
villains of the eighties movies so I
this is the the
him being the best thing about dead and
buried the best thing about death line
is Donald Pleasence oh yeah playing a
turtle
crotchety with his buddy yeah fling in
the back well we have tea bags now what
is this about
I was like Jen married the guy who's
making them he does say it's voodoo and
technology and medical breakthrough yeah
he basically says it's both or says he's
not going to tell but he was gonna go to
his grave yeah yeah I tell you what it
was he'll take the secret to his grave
basically he says it's either voodoo or
it's a medical breakthrough it I'm gonna
take it or a combination or combination
taking it to my grave also dead and
buried has a really good ending and the
first time I saw it I did not see it
coming you know what I mean yeah you
know what I'm talking about think
reanimate er took a lot from this
it may have yeah and maybe from beyond
may have taken so now I think just
re-animator yeah from this yeah this
there's you know about guys that can
bring people back to life yeah that kind
of stuff well that goes back to
Frankenstein but when you see dead and
buried you'll you'll see exactly what it
is I'm talking about I want to spoil it
in the end but it's very much something
like out of a Lovecraft
spin-off yeah it's because there's a lot
of stuff in there that kind of reminds
me of the science see guys out of from
beyond and yeah and reanimate her it's
that same type of thing well I like that
it kind of had a little bit of boat that
kind of had combining stuff and then it
had like a black magic key thing you
went on to so that's kind of cool yeah
but yeah so like I said I'm Gary Sherman
made some other movies I think later on
he made poltergeist 3 which hmm that was
the one with a mirror all the mirrors in
the building right yeah I don't know I
never saw a poltergeist 3 yeah I think I
saw that one it wasn't it was yeah you
see by the time you get to three it's
not any good all even though Halloween 3
is my favorite of the Halloween's I'm
sure a lot of people like Halloween
through yeah even it has nothing to do
that's not it
like that movie I came up with that
movie you know I love that movie I want
to get that on blue I think the only
reason it piss people off was because it
didn't have Michael Myers and yeah I
haven't seen the other ones so the first
Halloween I saw was Halloween 3 yeah I
actually kind of liked that idea and
it's like I don't know why they didn't
do the anthology thing but I will think
that they kind of do that kind of [ __ ]
now we should have done that again
called you know Halloween 9 and have
nothing to do with it just to make it
and it probably would now now it is you
know when Halloween 3 came out we didn't
have the internet so we didn't have to
hear anyone everyone whining like 24/7
about it but now it's I would revisit
Halloween 3 and reboot that like what if
that dude had a secret descendent who
hasn't had improved on that technique
you know the man yeah and he kind of had
a company like silver shamrock called a
movie they should call it silver I can
call that [ __ ] silver shamrock yes yes
indeed somebody's that would be a good
move don't make her daddy do that
because I love the conceit of like
putting on a mask and it [ __ ] up yeah
it's a hard reboot of of Halloween 3
even though the main bad guy in silver
shamrock refers to the guy in Halloween
3 that'd be awesome yeah somebody needs
it somebody get on that something like
it yeah they think well you know sue me
you could say well how could you use the
name silver shamrock everybody would
know what it was after he tried to kill
all those little kids with the mask you
could think of a way to get away yeah
that's what I mean you'd be creative you
guys that names silver shamrock man
you'd get a lot well yes because that
movie like horror fans know exactly what
that is yeah
and also it's a real evocative kind of
name you could do all kind of like I'm a
graphic designer so I can see I can feel
about like the low key to make a shirt
like that man with that with the pumpkin
on it with a pumpkin jack-o'-lantern
yeah a silver shamrock on it man yeah
and then like I said every time you wore
it this song would get stuck in every
yeah yeah and everybody be like nice
sock terrible computer graphics I know I
was like what is amber 16 what are the
coolest things that I liked about
Halloween 3 I always liked 80s horror
movies that have the stones
kill off little children yeah that kicks
ass kids laying on the floor and all
roaches and crickets ran out of his head
yeah cuz like when you saw that as a kid
you're like lost it that could happen to
me lost I'm a little kid like that
little kid yeah and his dad's running
from a snake or was it the mob running
from mistake kids yeah weaponize that
kids head blew up into snakes and yeah
up into snakes and crickets and roaches
and yeah that's a good idea
it was yeah like I said somebody needs
to get on that yeah I do you make it
heavy watching TV for it to activate
yeah yeah they'd have to see the
commercial it's such a great concept
shot that thing in there shot that
little bit of Stonehenge in T and blew
your head up yeah it's a piece of donut
yeah we're not even kidding about that's
awesome but yeah all right so damn drew
it's [ __ ] from thousands of years ago
[ __ ] up nowadays TV it rots your
brain
[Laughter]
yeah all right all right so that'll do
it for our double features a Gary a
Sherman double feature today dead in bed
and death line aka Romi's both good mama
give it to it I'm gonna give it a dead I
actually like dead and buried better
because it's it's structured like I said
it more like the fog we're like a ghost
story type thing you know it's you know
fudou zombie type of thing but it has a
similar kind of vibe where the other one
is more like police procedural across
with kind of chud type of stuff going on
so yeah so that's just my preferred
medium but they're both very good so
check them out like I said dead unburied
is from 1981 death line came out in 1972
in the UK 1973 over here called raw meat
poster like I said doesn't have anything
to do with the movie so don't even pay
attention to it even though it's a nice
piece of artwork but that'll do it for
our latest movie retrospective hope you
guys enjoyed it remember if you liked
the show to like share subscribe and all
your social media if you'd like to
financially support show you can go to
our patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account where you
can give a one-time
nation remember that our movie
retrospectives just like this one here
come out every Friday we also do a 13
o'clock matinee which is three new
movies in the theater that comes out on
Sundays and our regular episodes come
out every Tuesday so keep an eye out for
those and we will see you next time
bye